the age-old issue of mom shaming is
highlighted in the new April edition of
Elle magazine mom shaming is when
mothers are made to feel guilty for
their parenting decisions including how
they feed dress and teach their children
in a moment we're gonna show you ways
for women to fight back on this but
first see what happened when we met a
few moms who shared experiences that may
sound familiar want to go to the park
Bob's mom shaming means that a mom is
being made to feel bad or somehow shamed
for the way that they're caring for
their child I feel like I think about
breastfeeding or I think about feeding
your kid kale because there's a lot of
pressure to feed your kid everything
organic and everything healthy and it
could be something as little as you
don't put socks and shoes on your baby
because they've kicked him off set your
snacks
it's easier to look at other people and
see what they're doing wrong I don't
know it sometimes feels like a way of
building like their confidence or
certainty that we're actually making the
right choices I don't know yeah I was a
good answer I'm probably guilty of
having had thoughts around you-know-who
that's not the way that I would do
things I definitely mom shame in my head
I will be the first person to say that
I'm I'm eating crow every step of the
way
[Music]
it takes a lot especially when you have
like a four month old like I do just to
get out of the house it takes a village
every mom should help one another race
each other up the best advice I'd give
to a mom is to go out there and find
your tribe find women who are in your
same situation because there are people
out there that really need help and they
really need that community come on
finding a tribe may not be that hard for
moms in this country because many women
are in the same position according to a
2007 teen study sixty-one percent of
mothers say they were judged for their
parenting mostly by family members Oh
magazine executive editor that's Emma
rosenbloom joins us along with Heidi
grant she's a psychologist and author of
reinforcements how to get people to help
you good morning to you both morning I
love this topic I remember years ago
when my kids were in elementary school
and I brought cupcakes from the store
didn't bake them myself and a mother
says to me oh you didn't have time to
make them
and I remember explaining it to her and
then I thought beeyotch what am I even
explaining this to you but I thought
right yeah so I so mom my point I'm
making is mom shaming is not new now so
why is it happening now and what's
different about it do you think Emma so
I think in the past 10 years with the
rise of social media and platforms like
Facebook and Instagram particularly mom
shaming has really been amplified and
it's turned parenting into this kind of
competitive sport so our article looks
at this movement against mom shaming we
looked at a group of women that call
themselves unicorn moms and their
tagline is a perfect mom is like a
unicorn it doesn't exist and so they
really wanted to
judgment-free zone for moms to be able
to be themselves and not feel this
negative feedback loop on behind this is
what they say a mother who's not perfect
enjoys alcohol and has a sense of humor
and couldn't care less what you think
that's what you said about the role
social media plays because a lot of
images on social media can be
misconstrued we don't know the backstory
right and you give a case a point for an
example where a woman was at an airport
talking on the phone with her children
lying on her legs on a blanket and she
was ridiculed yes over the Internet it
turns out lose her job right and it
turned out that she'd been waiting at
the airport for hours that she was with
a ten-month-old
I mean any parent would sympathize so
what can we do to change that anything
well you said there's a science in our
brains that where were I do I mean part
of what's part of the reason why it's
happening in the first place is that
people mothers feel a lot of insecurity
right it's it's something I think most
mothers feel either consciously or
unconsciously that they have to prove
themselves to themselves and to other
people as moms but there's no handbook
for how there's no objective way to know
what the right way to parent your child
is and so there's a lot of uncertainty
what happens is when we when we
experience a lot of uncertainty we tend
to try to cope with that by creating
certainty so I decide this is the right
way to be a mom
and therefore if you decide to parent in
a different way that's really
threatening to me right that means maybe
I'm wrong so so a lot of what happens
online or even in face-to-face
interactions it feels like an attack and
it is an attack but it's really coming
from a position of defensiveness right I
want to believe that I'm right so I
think part of the solution is getting
moms to feel that we don't have to prove
ourselves that actually being a mom is
something you have to learn to do and
and that attitude actually really helps
people that feel less threat so so what
you're saying is that it's not just that
people are judgmental jerks but they
feel threatened because your mother is
such an emotionally fraught experience
to begin with and you come at it at a
place of I hope I'm doing this right and
if you're not doing it right if you see
somebody doing something differently you
can lash out and we point to celebrities
who are clapping back
get haters Chrissie - Chrissie team of
somebody who is both real about
motherhood but also presents this kind
of beautiful image of it and she's just
funny about it which i think is very
approachable and the women that we spoke
to in the article - said that
approaching this with a sense of humor
has been very helpful because nobody's
perfect and it's really hard for
everybody and Heidi we're going to make
mistakes mothers make mistakes and
that's okay absolutely no one's born a
good mom it's sort of impossible because
there's not only not one way to parent
there's not even one way to parent in
your own home I have two children I
parent them a little bit differently
because they have different things they
need from me so we're gonna make the
series - yeah you get your experience
and you grow and so people like chrissy
teigen are so helpful because they give
other women permission to say yeah you
know what i am making tons of mistakes
and that's okay i'm learning our home is
an oasis of tranquility we got was there
are gonna be a times where you feel
totally out of control and that's okay
is there advice or one nugget that
people can be given to let themselves
off the hook I think there's a point
where if you're feeling too much in this
feedback loop of negativity to disengage
a little bit to maybe get off of
Facebook groups to maybe not go on
Instagram and see these perfectly
curated versions of motherhood that
exists there I mean I have a
one-year-old and a three-year-old and
I'm lucky if I can get out the door
without some kind of meltdown tantrum so
to see that kind of perfection sometimes
can make you feel insecure so just don't
engage and don't comment well I felt
like I was born to do a gave birth to
twins my son Jake and guilt right now
that go with their the mommy guilt but I
try to work on that every day guilts
never helpful is it no no no yeah
stop doing that yeah I know thank you
both you can read the full article in
the new April issue of Elle it's on
newsstands today and on Elcom but we
like it when you buy the magazine